c'était l'assemblée annuel général de
Glenn aujourd'hui en Suisse le mouvement
d'éducation et de défense des
actionnaires le médaque est sur place
pour questionner la société sur sa
responsabilité dans le dossier des
rejets industriels de la fonderie
Noranda en Suisse on retrouve ce soir
Willy Gagnon qui est le directeur
général du Médoc bonsoir monsieur Gagnon
bonsoir comment allez-vous très bien
pourquoi êtes-vous en Suisse pourquoi
êtes-vous allé en Suisse et
expliquez-nous la démarche que vous
poursuivez ici
bon d'abord je suis personnellement à
actionnaire de Glenn j'en fais une
affaire personnelle évidemment je suis
directeur général du Médoc puis le Médoc
est embarqué mais je me suis rendu en
Suisse parce que je vois vous le dire
bien franchement je viens d'habiter ma
mère habite loin une Randa et puis ce
qui se passe avec cette compagnie là
m'interpelle personnellement
m'interpelle personnellement mais je
conçois évidemment que ça interpelle un
paquet de monde d'ailleurs à l'appui de
la démarche que j'ai entreprises il y a
tout un tas d'organismes de défense de
droit qui sont qui sont qui sont joints
qui sont joints à moi pour soutenir les
questions soutenir ce que je faisais
quelques questions donc quand j'en aurai
eu
vous savez comment ça fonctionne les
assemblées d'actionnaires on est
normalement limité à une seule question
à chaque fois qu'on va qu'on va au micro
il y a d'autres gens qui sont là aussi
pour poser des questions je leur ai posé
essentiellement trois questions pourquoi
pourquoi pas le 3 nanogramme tout de
suite vous savez toute la controverse
entourant le 15 novembre on est
évidemment pas des scientifiques mais on
a vu la chose passer on leur a demandé
si Glenn corps allait indemniser des
gens on sait qu'ils ont dit qu'ils
allaient déplacer un quartier au complet
qu'est-ce qui en est des autres
personnes qui ont été polluées par
l'usine qui ont subi les pollutions de
l'usine et puis on souhaitait leur
demander d'arrêter de faire la menace de
fermer l'usine vous avez que c'est une
menace qu'ils ont répété à plusieurs
reprises verbalement puis par écrit on
s'est demandé si ils allaient fermer
l'usine s'ils sont pour fermer l'usine
dites nous là puis si vous êtes pour ne
pas fermer mais arrêtez de polluer et
est-ce qu'on a répondu à vos questions
évidemment évidemment pas vous savez
chez nous au Médoc on a l'habitude
d'aller dans des assemblées
d'actionnaires de poser des questions et
de pas vraiment avoir toujours des
réponses
quand on fait une proposition
d'actionnaires la société est obligée de
répondre par écrit dans sa circulaire
mais en Suisse pour faire une
proposition d'actionnaires il faut avoir
des seuils de détention d'action très
élevé beaucoup plus élevé qu'ici au
Canada au Québec mais ce droit là se
déni droit là et compensé par un autre
droit qui existe en Suisse qui existe
pas chez nous donc quand on pose une
question en assemblée
la compagnie est obligée de répondre
donc de ce qui est pas le cas ici donc
la période de questions se trouve à
l'intérieur de l'Assemblée porter au
procès-verbal de l'année suivante et
puis la société doit répondre mais nous
a répondu ce qu'on irait jusqu'à
qualifier d'une bêtise de nous a dit des
choses qu'on savait déjà donc ils ont
réduit leurs émissions depuis une
vingtaine d'années substantiellement et
puis ensuite de ça qui vont faire une
zone tampon le fameux déménagement de
quartier mais c'est pas ça qu'on leur
demandait on voulait savoir qu'est-ce
qui en est de la règle du 3 monogramme
et je le répète là on voulait savoir
s'ils allaient des dommages et des gens
et on voulait savoir s'ils allaient
cesser les menaces de fermeture donc ils
nous ont servi une recette qu'on connaît
bien c'est à dire celle de répondre à
compris de la question et donc est-ce
que vous diriez dans ce cas-là que dans
cette grande assemblée d'une grande
entreprise multinationale qui est
partout dans le monde le sort de la
fonderie Crown n'occupait pas beaucoup
les esprits des dirigeants d'entreprise
évidemment pas mais il y a d'autres
moyens pour s'arranger pour qu'ils ça
occupe plus leur esprit une prochaine
fois vous savez vous le dites vous-même
ils ont des activités de partout dans le
monde il y avait une vingtaine
d'intervenants peut-être plus ce matin
j'ai pas été capable de tous les compter
mais les questions pleuvait sur le
conseil d'administration il y avait des
questions sur toutes sortes de toutes
sortes de sujets à commencer par la
pollution mais aussi la question des
droits humains le respect des
travailleurs il y avait un autre
représentant d'un organisation
québécoise qui était sur place aussi une
organisation syndicale qui a posé des
questions sur l'éventuelle création d'un
stering cognity comme ils disent en
anglais le regroupement différents
acteurs du secteur mais c'est ça
la pression on peut monter on a
rencontré toutes sortes d'autres toutes
sortes d'autres actionnaires il y a un
groupe d'actionnaires d'Australie qui a
fait une proposition d'actionnaires ils
ont été capables de le faire ils ont
réuni suffisamment d'actionnaires pour
avoir les seuil
une proposition traitant de traitant du
charbon ils ont obtenu plus que 29% du
vote c'est un score exceptionnel dans
les circonstances dans les circonstances
et puis on leur a parlé maintenant on
sait comment faire pour aller chercher
des gens pour faire une proposition
d'actionnaires puis la prochaine fois
peut-être que ça se ressent ok donc ce
n'est pas 20 ce que vous avez fait ce
que vous avez fait monsieur Gagnon ce
n'est pas 20 dans votre esprit vous
battez quelque chose pour faire pression
sur Glencore mais vous comprenez que
quand on sera dans une assemblée
d'actionnaires on s'attend à ce qu'on
nous dise non on est on est rompu à cet
exercice là vaut la peine de le faire
on nous dit non on peut on peut revenir
à l'avenir ça n'est pas ça n'est pas
toujours ce n'est pas toujours les la
première réponse qui vaut évidemment on
est parfaitement conscient de
l'environnement dans lequel on évolue
c'est plus compliqué d'aller à une
assemblée en Suisse que d'aller à un
assemblée au centre-ville de Montréal
pour nous vous le comprenez ça aussi et
puis les seuils comme je vous le disais
les seuil de détention d'action sont
plus une liste une grosse bataille mais
il y a beaucoup de gens qui ont appuyé
notre démarche là si plusieurs
regroupements les mers offrants le rrse
la Fondation David Suzuki l'action
boréale au secours
qui vont s'ajouter on s'organise s'il le
faut merci monsieur Gagnon merci c'est
très intéressant de vous avoir parlé
d'avoir suivi votre démarche à la
prochaine
merci beaucoup
pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI